we both got a little bit mental illness
right
hello everybody welcome back to big mood
where the moods are big and the tits are
small some of us we're coming at you
live from justice living room and you're
watching the video right now we're all
addresses living room and if you're not
watching the video you've got to come to
the video that's where the fun is the
small tips on the tender small tits are
in my living room all of the small all
of the small tits are here all is
silliness aside we're talking about
mental health today so get serious yes
you get [ __ ] serious turn your nips
down turn your butts up I'm trying
really hard not to say what it's mental
illness this girl's comparing a bedroom
or a bunch of tourists and like her
bedrooms like super cliche
this is mowing yeah nice and beautiful
my pride and joy and then she goes over
to her sisters and sister says [ __ ] up
holding like 16 cans of Pringles is a
Campbell's act fans of Pringles [ __ ]
up she goes and this moistest us it's
mental illness thank you I wish I was
British I mean technically I am my DNA
is I just wish I was like that's really
I am okay
I know some American ass [ __ ] ever I
hate my DNA says I'm like 68 percent
23andme said that I'm not 60% British
I'm point four percent Native American
most of my blood is Iberian so you know
Berrian I be rien you've seen and
Portugal that's cool we suck at
geography because we're Americans
I'm really like there's countries I
disappear all the time like I forget
what I get renamed in a symbol as
Constantinople knows it okay yeah
23andme I am 72% Constanta low billion
no idea what that man representing for
the 50% dumb [ __ ] over here for those
of you out there
oh I'm 2% on [ __ ] oh my god what region
the dumb [ __ ] media oh yeah I'm done
before yeah alright guys [ __ ] mental
help you set your asses we're talking up
it um I feel sad Oh phantom that
all-encompassing Gina but I feel like um
you know the world is chaotic it also
got like slam [ __ ] into all of us
three months ago like I want to go back
and react to videos of everyone setting
goals and me like 2020 and make it my
[ __ ] this is your like watch a man if I
can crush it I'm gonna tour the world
why did everyone feel like 2020 was
gonna be there [ __ ] like everyone that
collectively thought this was gonna be
like the turning of their lives and you
know what they weren't credit really is
it's like I think everyone had like a
sense that 2020s gonna be big and
everyone thought it was a positive kind
of big but it's actually nothing well
it's like a
she was happening yeah the amount of
change that's happening and stuff is a
good thing in the big picture it's just
chaotic because growing pains for sure
going in are the worst and it feels like
there's something new that's big every
month - it's not just like one big thing
that we're all getting through it's like
oh you got that covered
okay here's a new one here's another one
yeah [ __ ] DJ Khaled another one okay
when we met just posted on her stories
or where the aliens are like I'll have
to get our editor to cut that picture
that's all we need now man I remember
when the murder Hornets were announced
and somebody made a meme saying June
2020 spiders entered the ring however
someone tweeted about the murder Hornets
racing like what happened to the murder
harness and then someone else said that
was a filler episode I hate the mob
mentality part of Twitter but I love the
humor part of Twitter
that shit's wild yeah but it gets [ __ ]
done - oh my god like kpop fan Twitter
one defeated it is terrifying I love you
I love you but I love when they took
over all those hashtags incredible they
took over a white wire yeah yeah and
they took over blue lives matter so that
they could destroy the hashtags yeah I
like pretty but maybe I was too rough on
them before I didn't understand them you
know and then when that happened I was
like you know what you guys are cool
here's a good yeah um so what uh what
are what have you guys been doing to
kind of stay Animal Crossing Center okay
I stopped avoidance that's your coconut
belly avoidance avoidance I really do
let's go what it really is no I'm not
denying it at all
yeah goodbye world I'm good
who knows how long cuz I'm happy good I
should have phrased it what is your
coping mechanism lately
whatever things yeah you're just also
avoidance I guess and lots of sleep
which what is it napping
yeah yeah escape yeah yeah mine is doing
a lot of working out and I've been okay
so it's gonna sound really weird cuz
like I've always been a really pale girl
that's not supposed to be in the Sun but
I've been going out in the Sun every day
for like an hour and I think it's
helping a lot
Hey do you usually I used to like never
go out in the Sun and then I'd like go
on vacation or something that I would
get [ __ ] burnt as [ __ ] and then like
I couldn't go on the Sun again for
another like six months but then now
I've been doing the like little by
little and I'm like I think I'm getting
vitamin D actually yeah a trying to take
care of myself
you actually like yeah you have a glow
to you mmm-hmm good you look [ __ ] hot
just like that lighting in the mirror
she's married she's married into a royal
family and she's just poisoning moly
it's you know there's arsenic and apple
seeds mm-hmm that you do believe
actually I was like your CV come home
with 150 apples it was about how they
take so much she's that person has math
problems you got when you were a hundred
fifty-two apples she beats to 16 how
many husbands loves as she had how many
well he dies and she carries on the
fortune that's nuts and others
I got a make him out a fortune first he
leaves just five lettuce leaves for you
for a funeral
this form of mental health yeah yeah
yeah true exactly
this helps the mental health yeah like
that is our all of our collective coping
mechanisms is talking just making it
into comedy you're fun funnies we're
just making some funnies I made the
mistake of trying to read fiction books
to escape I have been a strict
nonfiction reader for the past 15 years
I read at least two whole months but
it's always nonfiction because I like to
learn stuff when I read but lately I was
like maybe I should try some nonfiction
because I heard it was more relaxing so
before I go to bed and I asked Twitter
to give me a list of recommendations for
like some light fiction reading that I
could get into and these [ __ ]
recommended 1984 so I've been reading
[ __ ] George Orwell's 1984 way
did new parallels or what's going on
well I knew that it was about a
dystopian thing like a future and people
always like oh no we're in 1984 or
whatever but I didn't know the extent to
how parallel it was like the way that it
began and stuff and they just made
things way worse you didn't have to read
that in high school already know I read
Animal Farm um we had 1984 they gave us
a list and we had to pick ten books out
of that list
and so I think like mine was like to
kill a mockingbird Catcher in the Rye
Animal Farm like you know yeah you had
most of them like slaughter yeah
whatever the [ __ ] oh
Hachette yes that was there actually we
read that in fifth grade yeah yeah I
don't remember ever reading level that
is busy [ __ ] taking those what are
those [ __ ] areas to remember yeah
I literally destroyed my brain out of it
and I went into depth in in that and JK
other things yeah I've never tried it
don't it's stupid don't hurry
a story from that was that she would
like try it and feel good and then fall
on her face that wasn't the air
fresheners those different things I did
oh yeah we talked about like I don't
wanna get into it anyway because those
are my coping mechanisms back then when
I was thin right when I was a teenager
and my household was a wreck like it was
really bad where I really just did not
want to be in the moment cuz I'm like I
need to escape this is any way I can
and so that's when I turn to ya whippet
thing or whatever like the air freshener
thing I would like be huffing air
freshener like [ __ ] escape and like I
would like Colusa Nate and like that
world was a lot nicer than the one I was
living in so that's how I ended up like
turning into a party animal too like I
would sneak out of my house and like go
to a whole bunch of parties and I just
really did not know how to deal with my
life so I would just escape and now it's
as I'm 30 years old I'm still doing the
same thing but now it's animal crossing
like I was gonna say you're still doing
whippets girl's bangin on the door mom
cans no they were air fresheners getting
raped there's a for sure house you
should never the whipped-cream hands
okay no cleaner ones and my mom shits a
lot everything she does in a bathroom
yeah I wonder though like I feel like
there's probably a lot of people that
are turning to drugs and alcohol right
now during this time like and even if
they maybe only partied a little bit
during normal world now they're doing it
a lot like five days a week and they're
just like like I never drink but oh girl
they old wine no no okay every time we
start an episode jeana's like how long
does wine last and we're like people
days
six months ago it was like months oh
that's cool the bottles transparent cuz
the guy needs a green screen so I have
something weird my mental illness I had
a few things when I was little and it
was heared in the weirdest way possible
skinca mic yeah somebody got like an odd
smaller noise for now I have to get to
you and so when I was young I grew up in
a very troubled childhood and that kind
of manifests into some mental illness
right now and so I had what's that word
for it it's like Trick Daddy and when
you tricking the Minaya hairpin yeah
yeah I was obsessively pulling out my
hair when I was a kid like I had like a
bald spot up here oh my gosh you're
plucking my hair and the feeling is when
I pluck it out I'll look at them like
now the root on this one isn't the right
one it's not the right one like I would
have like pick at it so the point where
I gave myself a bald spot
and that's like I don't I think it was a
weird coping mechanism mm-hmm and then
what tip said I also from that I
developed Myka Myka Myka where it's a
it's a condition where you eat things
that you're not supposed to eat so pick
it out and I'll eat my hair I'm like wow
like I'll bite my nails off and I'll eat
my nails oh you're like the my strange
addiction people yeah so then I did what
age was what age was this Jesus from
like like six or something from I want
to say four till around whenever you get
your teeth pulled out when they start
falling out there's the only reason why
I stopped biting my nails because I used
to fight with my canines and then when
those teeth fell out I couldn't fight
anymore and that got rid of the whole
like male about your name and then the
the hair-pulling thing I used to pull my
hair and then
eat it and then my my my grandparents
saw and like they scared me out of it
like oh yeah like you're going bald and
you know if you go bald it's not pretty
so I stopped pulling out my hair and
then or like they would stop me from
eating my hair by saying oh you know
what doctors say that when you eat your
hair it travels through with your blood
and into your heart and it hurt it kills
your heart and then that would scare the
crap I'm feeling light it kids like it
that way that's gone because she stopped
so remember people lie to your kids or
just don't have kids
or just don't love anyone and then like
I just had and then I had like dude I
like a plethora of just [ __ ] that was
randomly cured like I only got to see my
mom once every four or five months and I
was like like obsessively or I was like
obsessed with her because it was my mom
that's my mother figure and I don't have
to see her so I collected everything in
a box from her like the napkin that she
used a sequin that fell out of her dress
and I yeah my issue is hella [ __ ]
hardcore yeah it was bad dude and then
like it was everything I kept everything
that I grew out of that too
and that like I don't know it wasn't
weird like I didn't think much of it
when I was young and then now then when
I grew up and I read about was like oh
[ __ ] I used to do that it is mental
health in it like it is that's me you
know but it me it cured I [ __ ] got
cured like this Chinese way possible how
did you cure it like I said like what
they scared I'm scared
they scared it out of me yeah I mean I
had one of those things too but not not
those those are pretty hardcore mine was
just I had a little bit of OCD when I
was younger where I would have like I
don't have to blink every time I walked
over a lot so like if there's a crack in
the sidewalk or like even like I would
picture like a grid over everything and
then if I cross the square and this
invisible grid I had to blink whoa how'd
you love that I don't know I think I
grew out of it too
remember one day I just stopped doing it
but I would always have to [ __ ] blink
over everything oh I had to make that to
work every like few seconds I went a
little weird rabbit twitch I used to do
that because I had a septum piercing
when I was 18 and I would like to touch
my top lip to it so it always just like
she smelled something bad just but
that's which got scared out of me by my
uncle seasons and he was like you know
when you do that your muscle the nose
and your or the muscles in your nose get
weak and then your nose falls off I was
like oh wow they were really great of
I'll give them that
yeah I had to pick my nose a lot and my
dad's friend told me to pick my nose
this was just I was very secretive about
it I only had a few times and I would
deny but my dad's friend told me that
like my nose would get super super big
if my nose and that he's like but don't
worry there's the way you prevent it is
you just kind of pinch it for a while so
I god kids are [ __ ] stupid I love it
tell your friends you gotta figure it
out I guess like from that on like I I
never understood I never knew growing up
in my teenage years was I lazy or was I
depressed
you're probably lazy enough to want food
delivered to your door right right yeah
definitely lazy animals you not cook so
if you are then you could try door -
yeah it will help you get through your
depression because you still have to try
to eat at some point you know got clean
afterwards yeah you don't gotta clean
afterwards you throw that [ __ ] away
so alright guys you've counted on
restaurants now they're counting on you
while the dining rooms are still mostly
closed a lot of places are open for
delivery door - is the app that brings
you food you're craving right now right
to your door with over 300 thousand
partners in the US were Taco Canada
Australia you can support your local
restaurants which we think is the most
important or you can still go to the
national chains like Chipotle Wendy's
the Cheesecake Factory my favorite thing
to order on delivery is this this hot
chicken sandwich I don't want to say the
name of the restaurant just because you
know I don't know but I get this hot
chicken sandwich from there every time
and it has a little slaw on it you guys
know I'm talking about the Louisiana
kind of girl no I love those anyway
that's what I get all the time on door -
right now our listeners can get five
dollars off their first order of fifteen
dollars or more and zero delivery fees
for their first month when you download
the door - app and enter code big mood
that's five dollars off your first order
and zero delivery fees for a month when
you download the door - app in the App
Store and enter the code big mood one
last time that's the code big mood for
five dollars off your first order with
door - thank you guys a mood yeah that's
right and if you're just as lazy and you
still want to get food but you want to
be healthy about it daily harvest has
got your back
because daily harvest they only use
fruits and vegetables they don't use any
preservatives they don't have any added
sugar or artificial ingredients so it's
super quick it just takes a few minutes
to prepare so like for me personally my
favorite is a pineapple and matcha
smoothie so it's like it already comes
in a cup and it tells you the
ingredients for example this one has
like pineapple kale coconut lime matcha
and vanilla bean and then you just like
add whatever liquid face that you want
so for me I like to put soy milk and so
once I do all that and then I put in the
blender I blend it up super easy super
quick snack and it's really delicious
and it ends up giving me like an
energetic boost I really love it so
stately Harvest is also committed to
minimizing their environmental impact
they're in the process of transitioning
to 100
percent compostable recyclable packaging
and are over fifty percent of the way
there already so they're good on the
earth as well so go to daily harvest
comm and enter promo code big mood to
get twenty five dollars off your first
box that's promo code big mood for
twenty five dollars off your first box
at daily harvest calm
that's daily harvest dot-com promo code
big mood so Gina back to what you were
saying um we were talking about laziness
versus depression I feel like I talked
about depression and mental health stuff
on my channel all the time especially on
my vlog channel and for me the thing
that had helped the most was having a
routine and and having structure it
creativity within the structure but like
having like this the same things that I
do every day to stay balanced and I do
that I do that because it's so easy for
me to slip back into a spiral and once I
start slipping it almost seems
impossible to get out of it and it
manifests itself as laziness at first
like procrastination and then laziness
and then I just can't get out of bed
because I am so depressed and I I feel
like that's what's kind of been
happening lately like within the past
month or so is just a slip for me at
least because in the beginning of the
pandemic I was still doing the routine
like you were almost more happy with the
Panda yeah the quarantine part of a
warranty part yet not that I mean
obviously not the butter that the virus
yeah but yeah the Courtney murder was
because I feel like my energy was being
spread out in so many different ways
with like auditioning and and this shoot
over here and this shoot over here and
it was you just felt like at the end of
the day I came home and I was so spread
thin that I didn't like know how to
focus on anything anymore so when the
forenoon first happened guy did feel a
lot more focused I felt like at least I
could do productions from home like this
and I could edit all my videos on time
and it was a lot more streamlined but
then yeah like lately I could I did get
sick
like physically sick not kovat but I got
sick where I couldn't really focus on
anything or get out of bed and then
that's when I got an animal crossing and
this and then that took a little bit of
time to break out of and then once I
finally broke out of that I felt
extremely connected to the world like
which is usually a good thing because I
was walking Moroz getting in touch with
nature more at stuff but when you're in
touch with the world and there's chaos
going on in the world I just feel like I
picked up all of that like I just felt
everybody's emotions like any like a
sponge yeah exactly
sadness anger uncertainty just a lot of
people like fear like just all at once
just like so heavy and compounding that
I couldn't like I couldn't like get out
of bed without crying and it was it's
just been it's been like a journey
getting out of that one again but yeah I
feel like developing habits is something
that can really help when you start to
slip and you get into those do you ever
like try listening to Eckhart Tolle
tolay or whatever because like if when
I'm so deep down like that like when I'm
so depressed that I don't even want to
eat or get out of bed or move like I
almost have to remember that my thoughts
can be separated from my reality kind of
yeah you try listening to that sometimes
honestly listening to him talk is the
only thing that will keep me from just
[ __ ] walking off the edge you know
what I mean like because I'm like oh
wait a minute a lot of this is I'm
honestly like if anyone hasn't tried
that yet just google him Eckhart Tolle
and like listen to his YouTube channel a
little bit kind of get into that because
that for me that will help at least get
me out of bed and like maybe nothing's
perfect but it's like oh now I remember
now I need to eat like I need to and
then you start to slowly move forward
again
yeah or if you're a book nerd like me I
like his books power of now and they're
hard to read though and especially when
you're depressed that's not the audio
book girl cuz when reading it's okay I
listen to the audiobook for both of the
ones I think you just said the are
blooming and awakening the newer yeah we
can the earth is literally oh my god
life-changing I freaking love that book
so much I think my Bible yes like it
changed like the perspective of my life
alright where's this called I'll look it
up listen to it I have both of them I'm
looking at it it's very good this one
yeah the kitchen yes
and you earth this is brand-new because
I bought it for Casey's because like I
said I got the audiobook don't try to
read it though if you're not a normal
reader because it's kind of thick like
just listen to it that was really heavy
but alright but the basis behind all of
that is to be in the president because
there's no pain in the present so it's
like bringing you back to reality
because all those anxious thoughts and
anything anxiety related is usually you
scared of things in the future or
panicking about things that haven't
happened yet that are out of your
control and any depression thoughts and
feelings are usually from something in
the past or something that you're like
dwelling on that already happened or
that is happening but when you're in the
present like just this moment right now
and that's why with meditation they say
to focus on your breath because your
breath is the present at all times
there's no suffering in the present and
that's what the I mean there's a lot of
like Buddhist teachings around that
there's yeah that I think Eckhart Tolle
is really great um I feel like the the
thing that it's weird though because the
thing that got me into it is into the
depression or like feeling everybody's
feelings is that a lot of that has to do
with that we're all one like we are all
a collective consciousness and so when
one part is
if you're very connected to that like
you will feel the hurt of that too and
that's when it becomes hard but I feel
like yeah coming back to the present
moment is always a good starting point
this is hard to practice all the time I
think that's why I tend to just do the
avoidance thing cuz it's just easier but
I've that's been my journey my own
personal journey especially during this
time like the world's time is just
really difficult so yeah I don't know
I've been putting it off it's kind of
like having homework to do and you're
like well it's due on Monday it's fairly
Friday night I got the weekend like
that's kind of how I've been approaching
is I've been very avoiding that which is
pretty pretty standard I think for me my
way of avoidance is probably like I get
lost in music I don't know I'm like one
of those weird music people who like my
whole life I've been kind of a lone
lonely single child lonely all the time
and so I've always gotten lost in music
so like I've been not doing well this
this past week but I just constantly
have my headphones in listening to music
that's like more upbeat and I just keep
[ __ ] finding things to do and like
it's almost like if I block out my
thoughts with music or a podcast or
something it helps me at least I guess
it's the avoidance part of that there's
still a lot of feelings you have to work
through but sometimes if you push past
them and distract yourself a little bit
then they don't hurt as bad when you go
to actually face them if you give
yourself some time from them but my my
newest strategy over the past couple
years has just been embracing everything
like embracing the feeling and just
hitting it head-on so instead of the
uplifting music I listen to like Lana
Del Rey and just like [ __ ] let it now
yeah those cry it out and then that'll
last like 20 minutes and then I can go
like yeah focus well I've done some of
that too like I've gone back and
listened to music from like middle
school and it's weird how like some
music from the 90s even like it's so
more emotional than like music now I
feel like yeah that's true though
yeah I don't know I definitely had a few
crises with with some music
beside that we all have pets that we can
cuddle up to
because I think I read somewhere with
that like having a pet and just holding
them kind of lowers your blood pressure
and helps with anxiety and stuff man my
cat is sick of me planning on running
away I know dude like if I cause me I
feel like my cats it's like such a
healer and he's like are you okay he's
like smother again I'm like you're so
sweet and also I'm hot I'm hot all right
she's crazy struggles and sausages so
cute to me too and especially like for
example if I'm playing or something they
like will they will not stop rubbing
their their heads on my hands cuz I'm
using it to like play the game whatever
not it's like I put the remotes down and
give them like full-on attention and
they're satisfied and I'm like thank you
I needed a break yeah no I know when
you're busy because the [ __ ] does it
all the time whenever I'm streaming
it'll do something really important like
in the middle fight or something he just
jumps up like some [ __ ] listen to me
and starts rubbing himself all over he's
so cute you don't so much by the way we
just taught him how to sit so how do you
knew that with treats my friend did it
with treats cuz I had him babysit my cat
for a few hours while the exterminate
the exterminator was over he texts me
saying you know I just thought you can't
how to sit and like okay are you gonna
teach him how to use a toilet oh yeah
love that maybe we'll see you never know
what's gonna happen to these points can
you imagine like teaching Maddie or
Sophie's hilarious in the middle of
night you go to the bathroom your dogs
just sitting there yeah get up there
Grambling with their like big old nails
I want to try that it's all I looked
into it for a while for my own cats to
potty train that like toilet trained
them and it's a pain in the ass you have
to expect a lot of accidents and
it's a lot of dedication they would be
cool to have to buy litter ever again
mm-hmm I will say taking care of an
animal is part like I've is really
healing like that's like a really good
aspect of or not aspect but like a good
way of getting out of depression is
focusing on something outside of myself
like with the responsibilities of taking
care of a another living being and then
like beautiful plants like this one in
the background of is like right on my
plate like putting it so far yeah it's
funny and then when I have my plant here
or the plant thinking you could kind of
see it right there yeah yeah all right
you know what guys I'm bored of this
household on different houses yeah I'll
meet you there girl guess I don't have
these my true friends left me and apart
tiny areolas big booties you mean where
does the yeah oh well we are a very well
balanced we both have qualities I will
say that there is um I have to admit I
did go see Nicky and Steve recently but
I think the world kind of opening up a
little bit and you know we're probably
gonna be back on our sets just needed a
home oh yeah so I went over there and
they helped me so much like feel better
I think just being around people like
it's been too many months of being
isolated yeah yeah we played a game and
we at home just shot on JK news that
whole weekend and so like everyone there
had been quarantined forever and so
anybody that was at that shoot I would
have no problem like seeing in my home
yeah
to be around friends like a few weeks
ago I was losing my mind too and I like
spent time with like another friend and
it was like oh this is all I needed just
someone listened to me what other
friends Jeana we need human time you
don't have other friends girl you're not
allowed yeah we have a Blood Pact and I
feel like you're breaking is I have like
16 other bedrooms to go to okay yeah I
mean like it's always so nice to just
talk to someone and a lot of times I
realize that people don't really need
advice or they just need someone I've
been to and it helps so much I didn't
know like for a while I didn't know what
the hell is going on with me I felt like
I was losing my mind
well then I saw my friends and I
realized oh this is all I needed I just
needed the company someone else and this
holy quarantine thing made me realize
that humans really are just animals and
language just we go nuts you know they
are very social creatures and it's very
funny how like just like the smallest
things like restaurants and stuff and
entertainment really does keep people
saying and you know it makes it sex like
um hello I'm [ __ ] losing my goddamn
mind
yeah you've been getting vitamin D but
not the right vitamin D I've been
getting a lot of Sun in vitamin D yeah
for some not the right mother's saying
Jess I volunteered to make a dating
profile for you what you're with your
virginity for me yeah what's your
picture I will stand in place for Jess
and you think you can Danny no you have
no game Jeff it's no no it's the game
like it's a numbers game it's a numbers
game I'm gonna swipe on also a devilish
profiles yeah just everyone that's hot
and then I was gonna be like hey my
name's Jess I have bad ass the owner
hang out and then they all say
that's not like you can be like 50 I can
do 50 we just merge them together so
this is just the numbers all four of us
why I widen it yeah we're gonna cast it
that all the way across Los Angeles oh
yeah it's a really wide net and then and
then like I'll just give him your
Instagram then you'll randomly wake up
to messages from random dudes like Cena
again isn't it it's gene again innit
oh yeah you'll get an excuse to play
around on a dating app yeah just be my
dating coach I don't know if this X has
been much better over here either though
cuz depression such a boner killer oh
you know it really is like there are
like waves where I'll be like I'm turned
on right now I should get it in but then
I don't know like it's just so fleeting
like because everything just feels so
heavy and what they've been doing to
like this whole according thing to keep
himself saying um we'll be like we watch
a lot of love island and I'm really
sleepy but you know I got a treadmill
and he's been really consistent on the
treadmill and so he actually plays
Animal Crossing more than me no he'll
play Animal Crossing on the treadmill
I'm imagining just the trashy is island
I just want him to have his own island
beside me to do you know I suppose see
what happens yeah they'd have [ __ ]
it'd be Gina Milan exactly I came back
after a month because I've been playing
and then my village is like oh my god
it's been a month without you died just
weeds everywhere yeah but I need her
crazy know why but it since I was gone
for a whole month
my weeds have been thriving yes really
yes and and thrive they will as will you
subscription to thrive market it's a
clean grocery
servus I love them actually been a fan
for years so you pay a subscription kind
of like like a Costco membership and you
get access to a ton of different like
foods and ingredients and and healthy
healthier stuff then maybe would be at
your local grocery store so for the
longest time like a lot of plant-based
ingredients were not available at the
store down the street and so I'd have to
go online but then the online prices are
super jacked up because they got to ship
it to you and stuff so thrive actually
just makes that a lot easier to access
it's super easy to find what you're
looking for like you just search any
ingredient it's kind of like the Amazon
of grocery stores and um yeah my
favorite thing to buy they're like my
guilty pleasure is uh
vegan marshmallows which are so much
better than regular marshmallows they do
it they are made of not gelatin instead
of gelatin it's tapioca starch I believe
and they're so freakin good and we've
been having like s'more nights on date
nights and stuff it's fun but they also
they tailor to seven to seventy
different diets and values like paleo
kita there's 70 diet I know I don't even
know the 70 things man it has all of
them I guess they got the spectrum of
diets going on and as a member you're
saving 25 to 50% off traditional retail
prices and they're carbon neutral
shipping is free on orders over $49 not
only do I feel great about getting a
deal on my favorite clean organic
products but I also feel great about
helping to support families who need it
most so in addition to membership
matching thrive market is matching
donations to the Cova 19 relief fund
dollar for dollar and they've actually
also always helped donate to charities
and stuff but right now in particular
they were donating to covert relief so a
thrive market is wearing 24/7 to make
sure members are getting their groceries
delivered as fast as possible and you
can learn more about their commitments
to customers and membership matching on
their website try that try thrive market
and become a member risk free by going
to thrive market calm /big mood join
today and you'll get up to $20.00 in
shopping credit towards your first order
that's thr iv'e
market.com / big mood to start your
risk-free membership and get up to $20
towards your first order derive market
calm / big mode big mood and since
you're a taking care of your tummy you
should also take care of everything else
of your body in your body and that leads
us to our next sponsor it is care of
which is a vitamin and supplement
subscription which I absolutely love
because I'm a sucker for cute packaging
so camp is a wellness brand that makes
it super easy to maintain your health
goals with a customized vitamin plan all
you have to do is go on the website take
a quiz see what you want to take care of
and they pretty much make a little
packet for you your own custom mix of
vitamins and has your name on it I know
it has you may want to know I love stuff
like that Union Daily packs are perfect
for on-the-go just throw it in your
purse or gym bag and go on your way and
also I love it because the whole
packaging is biodegradable kara also has
a bunch of yummy protein powders that
you can take there's one for your
immunity your gut and for some energy
the individual eco-friendly packs are
super awesome and they're so pretty so
like I said all you have to do is take a
short quiz online or where you figure
out your health needs and your goals and
you just repacks anytime I have mine and
I try to focus on sleep and energy which
is kind of obvious exactly what I need
it's super fun it's super cute and
convenient now for 50% off your first
care of order go to take care of comm
and enter big loot 50 again for 50% off
your first care of order go to take care
of comm and enter big mood 50 now you
might think Oh
during this quarantine I'm feeling
terrible and you're probably thinking
it's mental illness in it but now it's
just your lack of vitamins go to take
care of calm it's your code big mood $50
a song she says vitamin instead of my
tab in American change you
wasn't a lot of he'll know what I'm
talking about I secretly love her but I
think she got cancelled recently or so
she did yeah I think she got I am told
to keep track there's a lot of
problematic white people well I mean
dojo cat got canceled on the same way oh
yeah that's what I've been doing to to
cheer myself up is watching videos of
racist people get beat up and or exposed
Jesus good for my soul and make you
shadow version of you like that see the
new Dave Chappelle I saw this video
recently it was like a protest and like
there's like a white guy arguing the
black guy and it's like a white man
holding a confederate flag and this
black man in like a suit and like the
white guys like yelling like this flag
represents my family back then when we
protected our farm and we had to save
our farm from though that time blah blah
blah and then the black guys looks at
him and goes who worked on that farm oh
my god it was so good I always I used to
always get pissed and people would say
like white devil but then when I saw
that bitch's face I was like ooh that is
really a white devil that is your white
dog yeah this is scary look at Jordan
Peele [ __ ] movie the purge mask
that's pretty accurate see that movie
still oh I watched the platform recently
this combined with reading 1984 oh it's
long really was it a good combination
not been picking the right choices what
are you doing with your the platform I
will say Indy I know I've been trying to
balance but
but yeah I will say it was not
predictable I remember just remember we
were talking about it and like you
didn't find it predictable no I didn't
find it predictable but I mean I got in
I got frustrated though because it was
one of those movies where like the whole
movie is about them trying this tactic
to to like change the system and then at
the very end you don't even find out if
it worked
yeah no idea what I'm to interpret to
now like that [ __ ] so it's not even
worth watching about it
also I didn't like the acting but I did
like the concept I thought the concept
was good I just wished it was executed a
little bit better the premise was cool I
guess Lee got into mafia movies because
everyone their moms are like have you
seen the time pretty well yet who the
Tom Hardy one garona watch that legend
these are legend no not that one
oh wait no the new one the one way she
plays Alice Capone oh yeah yeah yeah
hold on I gotta look this [ __ ] up this
[ __ ] oh it's on my calendar two nights
I've been like watching old mafia movies
cuz I was never a movie buff so I never
really watched much and so I started I
watched um
hey fellas okay
I saw Goodfellas until the $7 you know I
got a little date in front of my
birthday what I finished Goodfellas for
the first time which I loved but like
for like a whole week I was upset by it
I was pretty pissed about the listing
yeah they give you everything you
[ __ ] [ __ ] we gave you everything
and then you stitched on them and I
started and then I watched The Departed
which was pretty good oh the depart is
good and the casino yeah oka scene is
that the one with Mark Wahlberg
no no that's deported oh the gamblers
what I was thinking about no I guess you
know very related I wonder how those
guys like the real-life like gangster
like for example Al Capone and stuff
like how did they deal with their mental
stuff cuz they have to be all tough you
want to again do a big-ass rail of coke
and then shoot something Plus usually
sociopaths end up at the top so they
don't have feelings towards
people and oh my gosh I was just
watching this this thing about I'm
pretty sure he was a sociopath this is a
guy from backing like 1800s where he was
like he's known as the greatest con man
of all time his name is Gregor McGregor
come on everybody with that name his
parents did not try at all so he's known
as a greatest con man of all time who
pulled off the greatest con of all time
he was very charismatic sociopath
whatever and then um he convinced these
rich noble people whatever that he was
part of this country the more like the
higher noble people this country offered
them to buy some land his country in
this lush area where you can like make
money and grow things and people okay
sure and they're like old and they
wanted this property to like retire in
so they would buy it for so much he made
like 1.2 billion in this time whoa
selling all this fake land and then like
promising them you know all this land
and then so ships of like a hundred
people at a time like hundred people a
time would go this lands fine it was
just a shitty marshland like it's like
the fire festival before David looks
like the shitty marshy land and then
like they would get dropped off there
and they're like no we probably
navigated wrong so the captain of the
ship whatever if you like we'll help
your back I'm gonna go look around see
if we went the wrong way and during that
time while he was gone and they were
stranded there hurricanes hit winds
marshy wetland mosquitos mosquitos
started eating everyone and they gave
everyone malaria about 2/3 of people
died and like a third of the people that
actually survived was because these
random British ships were going by and
they picked them up and there was like
five or six other ships on the way to
that shitty mosquito marshy land and
like the British had to like stop them
like hey do not go here and by the time
word got back to wherever he was he
already fled the [ __ ] country with
like
billions and he survived and he was
gonna be they caught him he was gonna be
put to death or whatever but the one
person he was good to remember him and
was like no this this guy's [ __ ] cool
like and then saved him give him a lot
of mana to pension he died happily ever
after
oh my god that just paid it really
ladies how are you got the story right
now never name your kids [ __ ] this
[ __ ] ass name to have sir last minute or
doing they'll be billionaires that live
happily ever after I guess sociopaths
man like crazy I had an ex that I I was
convinced is a sociopath afterwards and
I I told him that and then he said that
he was going to sociopaths cool dead
serious what the [ __ ] does that mean
he was going to sociopath group therapy
school why do you climb I mean I like I
don't like he will pass he with the
class to learn how to not be assessed
[Applause]
what about it cuz you have if you can
guys well they catch me if you can guy
he was a pretty good card under watch
that oh we haven't seen it it's so good
that me yeah but you can't wanted to ask
you you have had experiences with a lot
of different personality types and a lot
of scary personality types like how did
you learn how to deal with them because
I think like dealing with different
types of people it does take a toll on
your like just you as a person like your
own mental health because you don't know
like you can't relate or whatever it is
you're dealing with someone that really
is making your life very difficult like
how is it that you're able to like learn
and navigate learning to deal well
definitely therapy helped a lot but then
like learning what those personality
types were which is covert and overt
narcissism
basically is where it stems from and
then doing a lot of research on that
like different narcissus
some types and what they want and what
they're motivated by and how they work
and how they operate and how a lot of
them are very very smart and like
charismatic and good with words and
stuff which was what tricks people into
serving them basically just seeing
reading about that and then seeing
experiencing it helps me to see red
flags when they happen and all you can
really do is just like learn how to
avoid letting them into your life
because they're the kind of like taking
and give an inch take a mile types or if
you just give a little bit then they
completely I feel like we could do a
whole episode on this guys you would
love to hear an episode on how Nicky
learned how to deal with different
personality types let us know because I
really want to do this episode I am
ready with my pen and pad it's like I'm
ready to take notes I'm still learning
because you know in LA I feel like they
all conglomerate here I feel like they
say raffia different parts of the
country and it just is a very
concentrated area it's like on a magnet
or the ego and I grew up with them with
oh sorry just god no that's okay yeah I
grew up with a pathological liar and I
didn't realize she was a pathological
liar until I caught her so and so it was
just always it was like insane to me cuz
she was like a very important part of my
life and it was just like hey did you
eat my food no I threw it away okay so
why is it not in the trash can I check
out the trash and waking up with the
trash is still here like very small yeah
inconsequential no just like I tell if
someone like that - yeah it was like
insane and then um though the way that I
caught her was when so my good like my
very close family member died my cousin
and it was like weird I had like a
spiritual moment where I randomly fell
asleep and then I had a dream about him
and it was a most real feeling ever
since shortly after he passed away and
then I remember running to her and
telling her about it and then like years
later like 10 years later I was having a
bad day because it was like the
anniversary of his death so I called her
and I just wanted someone event
- and cry - she goes don't worry he's
fine you know years ago I had this dream
where it felt so real and then she
starts spewing my dream saying that
happened to her and I was just like
super weird you do realize that's my
dream right and then she's like no it's
mine I'm like I literally told you that
in your bedroom ten years ago she does
we must have had the same dream then you
know and then she couldn't accept this
she would make something which makes it
worse you know yeah and then so that's
what I finally realized I'm like oh my
god you're a pathological liar
and then it makes me wonder like did I
ever even know you like what if all your
stories are a [ __ ] like what I mean
I how am I supposed to know if anything
is real like I just feel like all of a
sudden this person in my life was a
stranger and it's like how are you
supposed to figure it out afterwards
like you know from now on well how do I
know the stories you told me are real or
not
that's like shitty feeling it's just
mm-hmm yeah that's really hard because
then you're like or any of our
experiences real click together it's
already our friendships real yeah like
those I think that was like one of the
most heartbreaking moments in my life
friend it's like you know what like I
don't think I ever knew you and I just
really don't talk to that person anymore
and because like uh it kind of like rubs
off on me a little bit as I grew up with
it but I had like it was never bad
freebus sometimes I feel the urge to
just be like no I didn't do that and I'm
just like I think to myself like why am
I [ __ ] no no yeah I need to survive
yeah it makes no sense and then I was
realist cuz like I was used to seeing
that but it's just it sucks I had this
experience with the person that they
basically said that like oh you know
they would say a lot of things about
other people that were like oh I'm not
this and I'm not that and it really
bothers me when someone's this or
someone's that and then like as time
goes on it's like that is you yeah it's
like [ __ ] it's yeah here - it helps to
notice when people kind of like say
things without even like you a prompt
why are you so you're kinda like said
this up yeah is not that person that's
their best defense make mechanism no to
to use projection as a weapon so that
it's like well I've been saying this
about you all along how could it
possibly be me like yeah that's why I'm
like that really like just like there's
so many factors in how we manage our
emotions and like our mental health like
it's literally like they're our worlds
like our family our personal
relationships our friends our everything
right like our careers it's so it's like
a lot of people struggle with like
having to do I mean I'm one of them like
I've been saying throughout this whole
episode I'm very avoidin apparently like
I use escapism to handle things but it
just makes me really wonder like how how
do you like how do you face things in a
healthy way like what what is the way of
doing it if it's not escapism cuz that's
all I know really like how do you yeah
yeah good yeah I feel like one of the
first steps is being aware of it so
that's healthy like you know you know
what's going on you're very where you're
not mmm if you dial about it you know
mm-hmm I think when you when you know
your life is not progressing and you're
just like doing things to like kill time
and or like move things out of your head
and you're not like basically you have
to get back to a place where you're
actually progressing in your life so
there's nothing I mean there's no real
answer of how to deal with things but
it's like you have to know accept it
like Gina said and then you have to be
able to get back to a place where you're
actually doing things for yourself and
and and moving forward I mean that's
definitely a big part of accepting
things is like you're not escaping
anymore you're like okay settled with it
and then move on yeah and then once
you're stable with your own life then
you can help others and engage in like
bigger problems or outside problems
because I feel like if you try to tackle
like you talk about all those different
circles like there's the world yes yeah
and then yeah and then your inner circle
and your friendships and then your
relationships and then yourself like
your relationship with yourself and
it starts with you and you know if you
don't have that stable you're never
gonna be able to deal with any of the
other stuff so I feel like sometimes it
gets so overwhelming you can get or like
I feel like I've experienced analysis
paralysis where I am so overwhelmed and
like I need to solve everything all at
once or I need to fix it all and and so
then I don't do anything and I think
that's where the avoidance comes in for
me at least I really hard to that yeah
but lately I've been you know just to
give some sort of solutions that have
been working for me lately I've been
going back to the whole like just you
pick two things that I need to
accomplish today just like to they can
be big or they could be small but like
two things that at the end of the day I
could be like I did this and I did that
and that way after each day goes by and
I've just done my two things whether
that's like paying my credit card bill
and editing a video or like recording
big mode and uploading tasty Tuesday I
at least can go okay I am like steadily
moving forward like Jess was saying like
I am progressing here so I have my feet
somewhat on the ground there and then I
can start dealing with outside things
like those two things are like make sure
to hit all the rocks on my island and
make sure that all my fruit and check to
the prices there's a lot of things on
this list yeah there's always gonna be
so many things and so you just got to
pick the two that bring you the biggest
reward for the day the 80/20 rule that
we were talking about before those rocks
are gonna give you more than the fish
okay so you don't really have to check
you know you don't really have to check
the fish on the other hand also I do
want to say like what helped me was it
doesn't always have to be something big
it could be as long as you're making
some sort of progress so like even yeah
I just get up and shower that day or for
some people it's so formally it's just
even if you just get up and stand up off
your bed one day you know yeah I'm gonna
little like in front of the window just
open the window and like look outside
and just stand in front of it like just
there's small things you can do but
momentum begets moment
like small things will lead to larger
things and then eventually you're like
okay I'm having a regular day again dude
that is so true because yesterday we
Casey and I took and Isaac we all took a
walk around the neighborhood like around
this time actually like near sunset time
so we like where we actually expose
herself to the Sun and then coming back
home I'm like oh man that like that's it
a lot for me like I feel good like I
didn't realize how much I needed that
that's exactly what I did for a while
too
like there's a lot of times where I was
like oh my god what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me I'm just like sad and just like
for like no reason and then I realized
oh right I haven't seen the Sun in like
a week so I'll just sit in the front
yeah soak up the Sun and then almost I'm
like oh this was good go outside stand
out in the Sun a little bit it's free
being present to like you're feeling
this you're where our flew by and I know
Joseph date with a movie what a day with
Tom Hardy yeah she'd look real nice
no I have naturally beautiful I have two
veneers but the rest of it I mean my
teeth grew and straight is [ __ ] they
just have straight teeth before yeah I'm
just get ready just I love all of you
ladies I can't wait to hang out all
together we're gonna do that see we're a
recording studio just opened back up yes
so as soon as next week maybe we got
together reunited it feels so good also
thanks for listening if you have any
tips for mental health stuff and stuff
that's been helping you the past couple
months let us know in the comments and
I'm sure that I mean this is a this is a
conversation do you know so I'm sure
everyone could use it in the comments so
because please I'm you know thank you
without fruit in your stomach and and
then you'll get way more anymore and
once again what is it what is it
I wanted to be mental health in it yeah
we want me to have not mental illness i
brough I both
[Laughter]